LIGHTNING, HAVE TO SERVE THE
PENALTY.
BECAUSE IT IS AGAINST THE GOAL
OVECHKIN.
ALEC OVECHKIN ON AY CALLED.
AN EXTRA SECOND MAY HAVE RUN OFF
THE CLOCK AS WELL.
THEY WILL PROBABLY LOOK AT THAT
CALLED BY STEVE.
NUMBER 40.T
DOUBLEHEADER.
TOP LINE ON THE ICE FOR TH MINU
ANAHEIM NET.
IN FRONT FORY BY
R?
>> YEAH, IT'S BEEN GOOD.
LUCKILY ENOUGH, I KNOW THIS TO
SHOT, HE SCORES.
2-D MANGIAPANE
GETS IT BEHIND AND A ALL I THE
LINESMEN AND REFEREE LETTING
EVERYOBUT QUICK.
>> Keith: AND STEAL WAVING AT
Y
BACKHANDS THE PUCK AHEAD.
DUCKS WITH A GOAL LATE ALLOW GR
PULL THE PUCK ALL THE WAY OVER,
MAYBE PUT THE PUS IN HIS
AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR HIM, PUC
SIMON AND HE SHOT OUV IN THE BO
TOWARDS THS
INTERCEPTED, ON IT TOO.
FINAL COUPLE O